your brothers and sisters in the slum
nap from Norway are establishing a
Masjid a dawa Center this Center this
Masjid this educational institution will
act like a beacon of light calling the
Muslims in Norway back to the essence of
Islam so give generously and Allah
azzawajal will give you even more
because when you I watch a Jordan
Peterson and you um said can I say it in
the way I I would normally say it yeah
and it sounded like quite nice to listen
to you know almost like singing
um what kind of feeling does it give you
when you go through that out of interest
is there a Zen like feeling I'll tell
you what it is the Quran states
that certainly with the with the
remembrance of God do hearts find rest
so if I had to summarize it in one word
it would be Tranquility
like I think a lot of people want to be
happy and like if you ask there's a film
called The Pursuit of Happiness we all
know about right A lot of people just
want to be happy but I actually submit
to you that I don't think happiness is a
good prolonged state to be no it's
unrealistic yeah and not just that like
if you think of it from a dopaminergic
perspective if you have spikes dopamine
spikes then you're gonna have crashes
usually I mean uh Andrew hoberman I'm
not sure if you should have him on a
podcast effect it's a person who speaks
about dopamine and these kinds well I've
been on antidepressants in in the last
couple of years and uh which ones were
you on I was on something called
Sertraline okay yeah
um not good for your sex life yeah yeah
yeah well uh I've heard that but
um I came off here I mean you know we
you know you you try but the point is is
um it made me realize being a pleasure
Seeker being someone who maybe doesn't
have a lot of self control and is
indulgent that that lifestyle I was
living pre-surgery was very
crazy like a lot of you know booze and
other things in women and and just
constantly looking for that Spike and
it's not a state of mind you can stand
for a consistent period of time
happiness yeah isn't isn't where you
should be aiming for it's that neutral
but content exactly place and and that
that makes a lot of sense to me in fact
I think Peterson has something very
interesting on this where he talks about
from a psychological perspective
and and this so you can look at it from
a biological or neurotransmitter
perspective like you know dopamine
having these spikes is you're it's going
to be followed by some kind of a crash
usually that happens huberman spoke
about it speaks about this quite often
but that's from a dopaminergic
perspective or from a neurotransmitter
then you have the psychological aspect
so this this idea of trying to seek
euphoric moments ecstatic moments is not
something either encouraged or
um kind of uh seen as as the ultimate
purpose from design perspective
and so
one of the great Scholars of Islam his
name is he said that the world is like a
shadow the more you walk towards it the
more it walks away from you so in other
words if you try and seek pleasure from
something in and of itself then you're
likely to not get pleasure from it so
from our perspective if you have a deep
sense of purpose and for us the
transcendental purpose is
um not a material purpose but a deeper
sense of spiritual purpose which is to
worship the all high that everything
revolves around that
then you get this state of Tranquility
for example or doing what they call
which are the remembrance remembrance of
God saying things like subhana or
whatever maybe subhanallah glory be to
God praise be to God I actually feel
myself getting relaxed I calm down it
calms me down in fact when I don't do it
on a daily basis if I don't read the
Quran or if I don't do these things I
actually feel more frustrated as an
individual I genuinely this is how I
feel I feel more frustrated as an
individual it's kind of like going to
the gym like I'm sure you know more a
lot about that you know it's the kind of
feeling that you're going to get like
the endorphins when you've finished your
workout
if you remove that from your daily
schedule your weekly schedule imagine
the kind of impact that will have on you
it's kind of like a spiritual workout in
that sense and kind of the way you're
describing it it's almost like the the
if I was going to relate it to YouTube
for example is like
the goal shouldn't be getting the big
views the goal should be enjoying
creating the content and and the work
that goes into it I guess and that's the
thing like for someone like myself well
I have to be honest with myself the
question I keep posing to myself is to
what extent are you doing this for fame
to work soon are you doing this for
money which is less less so but to be
honest for me we all have an eagle the
dragon is the fame for me or the dragon
is the recognition the validation I need
that validation and I I would be lying
to myself if I said I'm not doing it at
all that would be a lie all that I would
be saying for example
um I I don't care what people think when
you look at yourself almost in the third
person and it's very hard to do this
obviously but you know you've obviously
became a massive success and you're
interviewing Jordan Peterson and uh yeah
and yourself now as well doing all right
bro yeah uh but you know and I'm sure
you have your detractors and your real
big supporters and then there's those
people in the middle what is the broad
sense of how people think about you in
your opinion I think it's positive I do
think so when we talk about Traditions
Muslim Community I think it's positive
but it's always it's always going to be
the minorities that we look at like for
example if you get 80 90 likes and great
comments you're not you might not pay
attention to that you might you may pay
attention to the 10 of negative comments
yeah and that's that's a part of the
human psyche it's a neurotic aspect of
the Human Condition this last week is is
is is when you have a certain opinion of
yourself and a wave of people coming and
just say you're this you're that you're
that it you're just like am I like yeah
and it's it's brutal to the the ego do
you know who doesn't have that and this
might sound completely ridiculous but
Psychopaths I'm not sure if you've ever
seen them in interviews have you seen
like when they say I don't care what
people think I actually believe that oh
million percent they only care what they
think they don't get like these people
and if you're not a psycho but if you
don't have that psychopathy and I don't
think you do or I do but temperamentally
we do care what people think it's a
natural thing we need need to find
mechanisms to try and moderate that so
for me my mechanism is I ask myself one
question what do you actually believe on
this matter
what do you actually believe what's your
belief and so the first thing I say to
myself is whatever your belief is do not
compromise on that belief no matter what
whoever says what because the the word
one thing worse than criticism is having
cognitive dissonance
the idea that you have two contradictory
belief systems or you're acting a
certain way and you're saying something
else that internal inconsistency
produces in the long term a worse
psychological outcome so my first
question I ask myself is what do I
actually believe
if what I actually believe is X and I'm
saying it publicly because I believe
that that's the right thing to say and
there's a negative impact then that's
just a byproduct of Truth which is
you're gonna have to and it's quite
frankly it's a byproduct of success